Oh glycerin really doesn't want to mix in you just sort of see the blob hey guys
I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop where once again
We're gonna be doing some fun experiments with glow sticks
Last time playing around for glow sticks and the fluid inside we discovered some fun
properties of them like how to make them glow brighter by heating them up, or oddly by mixing them with dish soap
Today we have a variety of experiments we want to try, we're gonna see what happens if we mix a bunch of different fluids with our
glow sticks and see if they react at all
We'll try taking our glow sticks and popping them in the microwave to see what happens if we heat them up like that and then
We'll take a bunch of our glow stick fluid and we'll put it in the vacuum chamber to see if we get some glowing bubbles
because I think that would look really cool
We've got a bunch of glow sticks, and we've got a bunch of stuff to mix into them. Let's get started
I've got a whole lot of glow sticks cracked open into some cups
They aren't really activated yet because we haven't cracked open the colored portion in the glass vials,
but we'll do that one at a time and then try adding our chemicals and see what sort of reactions we get
There we go very nice, bright liquid this is actually a mix of three different colors
We've got like the green and the yellow and the orange I think all mixed together
Really interesting how it can look orange and green at the same time
Because there looks green, turning a little bit, there's more orange look to it.
It's really interesting. Now as a reminder for why we're trying all these chemicals
here's what happens if we mix a little bit of dish soap in with our Glo fluid
It suddenly gets way way brighter, like it was already very bright
And you mix that soap in and it just gets crazy like a lantern
But putting out all that energy has a cost, it no longer
lasts nearly as long. Once the soap is mixed in it gets very bright
but then it starts to dim after not too much time. We also discovered that if we go ahead and add more soap
after it's already started reacting and slowing down,
all of that light just gets sucked right out of it, and we're back down to barely glow. It's not even glowing any more
Craziness! So that was discovered completely by accident
Let's see if we get any other sorts of kind of similar results from any of these variety of chemicals.
Most of these are just picked at random because I thought they all might have different compositions, and I wanted to see if they would do anything
That looks like a cup full of lava
For this one we're gonna see what happens if we mix in some household bleach
It's actually reacting like something is bubbling and fizzing in there
I don't know if it looks like the color is changing. I don't think it's really getting any brighter,
but it is reacting
Let's see what's next
That's an interesting color right there, this one has four of the magenta sort of colored and one of the orange, and it's giving us
this sort of peach colored glow pretty fun. For this one, we are going to see what happens if we mix in some super glue
Here it goes
Color changed, and I think it's gotten dimmer. Let's add a little bit more
Oh yeah
That just got way darker
Something about the superglue is stopping the chemical reaction that puts off light
That's interesting, it also seems to be doing a really good job of actually mixing in, like there's not
clumps of superglue floating around or bits of it stuck to the bottom. It seems like it's just dissolved into the liquid
In the first video I talked about how the glow stick fluid has a very oily texture on my fingers
We'll see what happens if we just mix in a little bit of three in one oil
I think that's getting dimmer. We're losing light
Definitely less bright than it was a second ago. Let's try adding more
Much dimmer, pulls it way down almost as much as the superglue, I think
There's still a little bit of glow to it, but not very much
Well we got some cool reactions with the bleach, the superglue, and the three-in-one oil. We didn't get any change with the others, we tried
dish detergent, Isopropyl alcohol,
Glycerin, hydrogen peroxide, clear Elmer's glue, and methyl alcohol
But we didn't see any noticeable results
with our experiments done of mixing the different chemicals into our Glo fluid,
it's time to move on to our next test, which is going to be microwaving our glow sticks
I've got three identical glow sticks, and we'll prep them all differently to compare the three. One of them
I'll crack and leave out of the microwave, one of them I'll crack and put into the microwave, and the other one I'll put into
the microwave first and then I'll crack it and we'll see what difference in glowing brightness we get out of them
Oh, yeah, that's definitely getting brighter
That was about 10 seconds
You know it's not very warm, though
And I think it is supposed to be the heat that activate so I'm actually just gonna put it in for a little bit longer
Hopefully it doesn't explode in the microwave
All right, that's noticeably warm now
in my hand, and we can already see the difference between the microwaved one and the not microwaved one, it definitely is brighter
So now let's try cracking
the microwaved one that hasn't been cracked yet and see if it's the same brightness as the one that we cracked first and then microwaved
I bet it will be
Ooh, and it went very quickly that activated much faster. Might even be a little bit brighter
Maybe that's just because it's been cracked for only a couple seconds and the initial chemical reaction is brighter
We can see that the warm ones are definitely brighter than the cool one
And it does seem like the one that I microwaved first and then cracked is brighter than the one that cracked and then microwaved
Let's also try taking one of our cups that didn't really seem to react with the chemicals in it and put that in the microwave
and see if it gets brighter
This is the cup that had the isopropyl alcohol mixed in and it didn't really change much
so let's see if a couple seconds in the microwave heats it up
Oh, yeah absolutely heats it up and makes it much brighter
Oh and I started boiling it, even
That's isopropyl alcohol for you
Doesn't take a lot of heat. Oh, and it's dripping so I may have maybe melted through part of the cup or
Something like that I think yeah, I think the structural integrity of my cup is compromised. That is way brighter
Comparison next to the hydrogen peroxide which also didn't change it much. Heat definitely adds something
We've learned what happens when we mix a bunch of chemicals in with our Glo fluid and we've experimented with using our glow sticks in
the microwave to pretty great effect, it got quite a bit brighter
Now I think what we need to do is take a bunch of our glow stick fluid, put it in a cup and see what happens
to it in a vacuum chamber
Before I activate our Glo fluid and put it in the vacuum chamber
I do want the best glow possible, so I am gonna throw it in the microwave for about 10 seconds
I'm not going to add the soap though because I think that might change how it bubbles
and I'm afraid that it would be really bright, but then die out too quickly. So we'll have it warm
but no chemicals added to it
All right, pressure is dropping in the container. I see some bubbles starting to form
There we go, that is bubbling
It's about the coolest thing I've ever seen boiling
Now that I've seen what happens without any soap mixed into it,
I feel like I kind of have to try with the dish soap mixed in cause it does make it so much brighter
Let's give it a shot
Whoa
All the brightness is going away, not all of it, but a lot of it. Oh, and we get big old bubbles from the soap
It does look like some weirdo magical potion right there
But most of that glow is gone
It's interesting it just looks like there's a little bit of glowy on the very bottom, but that everything else has sort of stopped glowing
Add back some pressure
This is pretty wild yeah, we've just got a little bit of glowing on the very bottom of the cup
Pink too - there was one pink glow stick and four blue glow sticks. Look from the top down, you can also see that it's just
separated around to this ring at the bottom
Something about the soap and the vacuum really made it separate apart. Maybe that's just the pure fluorescent dye or something
I'm not sure, let's see if the cup still glows under a blacklight
It does, but not nearly as much
Here's the pink color that we mixed one of our other chemicals into and it still has a fair amount of glow
You can see just how dim this one is at this point
This glow fluid is a lot of fun to play with and we've got some fun ideas of what to do with it
But if you have any others let us know down in the comments
Hey guys, thanks for watching. If you're not a subscriber yet
just hit the bomb to get in the club. If you missed our last video or want to watch it again click up here at
the top. Click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow